aquí tenemos la gráfica de la función
igual a 15 entre x o al menos la parte
de los valores positivos de x lo que
quiero hacer en este vídeo es encontrar
el área bajo la curva de esta función
pero no con respecto al eje x sino entre
la curva y el eje y el área que me
interesa no se encuentra entre dos
valores de x sino entre dos valores de y
el límite de abajo es la línea
horizontal de igualar y el límite de
arriba es la línea horizontal e iguala
al cubo pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo por su cuenta una forma de
pensar en esto es trabajarlo como lo
hicimos con las integrales definidas con
respecto al eje x pero ahora parece que
las cosas se han intercambiado ahora nos
interesa el eje y vamos a reescribir
nuestra función y la vamos a reescribir
en términos de x y es igual a 15 entre x
lo que significa que si multiplicamos
ambos lados por x nos queda x por jeff
igual a 15 y si dividimos ambos lados
entre y nos queda
x igual a 15 entre estas dos funciones
son equivalentes como nos ayuda a esto
de acá piensen que para calcular el área
vamos a tener varios rectángulos acá
aquí tenemos uno aquí tenemos otro y acá
uno más nos interesa el área de cada uno
de estos rectángulos la base de aquí
será x que podemos expresar en función
de ya que sabemos es 15 entre y ya que
será igual la altura la altura será un
cambio muy pequeño en ella por lo que el
área de cada uno de estos rectángulos
será 15 entre y deje queremos sumar el
área de todos estos rectángulos desde
que es igual a hasta que es igual al
cubo esto es lo que hace nuestra
integral definida que va de a a al cubo
estamos acostumbrados a ver estas cosas
con x y de x pero aquí tenemos 15 entre
y de g vamos a evaluarlo tomamos la anti
derivada de 15 entre i d i y la
evaluamos en estos dos puntos la anti
derivada de uno entre y es el logaritmo
natural
ahora absoluto del 15 por el logaritmo
natural del valor absoluto de jeff y
esto lo vamos a evaluar en nuestros
puntos finales y al cubo y tenemos 15
por el logaritmo natural del valor
absoluto de al cubo menos 15 por el
logaritmo natural del valor absoluto de
f
simplifiquemos esto aquí potencia tengo
que elevar para que sea igual al cubo
sería 3 y el logaritmo natural de él es
a qué potencia tengo que elevar para
obtener el es uno así que es 15 por 3
menos 15 lo que nos da 30 y con esto
terminamos